وعلى الصعيد السياسيه اختتمت في جده اعمل
اليوم الاول من الاجتماع التشاوري
لمستشاري الامن الوطني
وممثلي عدد من الدول بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه ويشارك فيه ممثلون عن نحو
اربعين دوله
وافادت مصادر دبلوماسيه مطلعه للجزيره ان
محادثات اليوم الاول تمت بشكل ايجابي حيث
اتفق الجميع على ان احترام وحده اراضي
اوكرانيا واسيادتها يجب ان يكون في صميم
اي تسويه سلميه واشارت المصادر الى ان
حضور الصين في اعمال الاجتماع التشاوري في
جده يمثل خطوه ايجابيه باتجاه فتح فتح باب
اوسع للمشاورات والوساطه مع موسكو
يعمل فريقنا في جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في اجتماع مستشاري قاده الدول
على صيغه السلام هناك ممثلون عن 42 دوله
من قاره عده مقاربات سياسيه مختلفه لشؤون
العالميه لكن الجميع متحدون في اولويه
القانون الدولي ولهذا السبب اقترحت
اوكرانيا صيغه السلام يجب اعاده النظام
الدولي القائم على القواعد الذي انتهكه
العدوان الروسي من المهم جدا ان تجري هناك
على هامش اجتماع جده مفاوضات ثنائيه مع
الشركاء